hey youtubers it's Charlie so they've
been releasing some promo pics from
Batman V Superman that haven't appeared
in the trailers and we have to talk
about something something something dark
side earlier today is part of like this
big Empire magazine rollout they posted
this picture which is very clearly
Batman looking at the symbol of Darkseid
a lot of people were like what is this
Kratos is this God of War
no definitely Darkseid Batman V Superman
new gods WTF we haven't even gotten the
holy trinity yet what's going on with
new god stuff well based on what we know
about the movie
this is Batman having a nightmare
literally like the toy for this when
he's wearing that outfit is called
nightmare Batman so it sounds like this
is part of his Superman nightmare like a
Man of Steel when Superman has the
nightmare about being buried and all
those skulls of the humans same idea but
you have to remember Batman is a human
he doesn't have any alien tech so this
is probably something that's happening
at a nightmare I've seen a couple of you
wonder if this could be visions that
someone is giving Batman he's not
hallucinating the forces of apocalypse
like we see this trailer here - like
where he's afraid of Superman he's going
to capture him unmask him and you see
these pair of demons but the weird thing
in all this that doesn't necessarily add
up is that Batman doesn't have
superpowers he's not prescient he
wouldn't be having visions of the future
he doesn't know anything about new
Genesis or apocalypse the new gods
Darkseid so why would he have a
nightmare about this symbol I understand
that the pair of demons you could write
those off as being Superman minions
wearing super suits Batman could imagine
some sort of alien threat but I don't
understand how his mind would
immediately go to Darkseid usually using
your mind when you hallucinate or you
have nightmares about things they're
made up of a combination of things that
you've heard things that you've
experienced things that you've seen so
unless Batman has seen all these things
before he wouldn't be hallucinating them
so really just more questions but
literally what I think is going on in
the movie is they're just teeing this up
for Justice League we're gonna see a
version of the New Gods in Darkseid in
the movie somewhere eventually rewind to
Avengers age of Ultron Thor has a vision
of the Infinity Gauntlet and in things
that Thanos is working up to but only
because the mind gem showed it to him
so who would be showing Batman these
visions I wonder if he hasn't seen them
before I love how their nuclear blast
just going off in the background
is really like the end of Flashpoint
like when just everything goes to
complete [ __ ] as confusing as this all
is I am really happy that they're
turning these cosmic cards over this
early like yeah we are definitely gonna
be doing this at a certain point we
wouldn't be showing this to you if we
didn't plan on doing it there's actually
stuff in the flash season finale that
they said that they're not gonna get to
till season 3 like image images that
appear like the flash museum bury in
prison they're like yeah we're not gonna
do that this season but we wanted to tee
that up so don't be surprised if
everything that they teased in Batman V
Superman isn't immediately paid off like
Wonder Woman is going to be happening
soon they'll probably deep in Justice
League mythology but it's mostly going
to be dedicated to setting Wonder
Woman's character up in the same is true
for all the other Justice League solo
films here's my big question for you
guys let me know in the comments do you
think that this symbol of Darkseid is
gonna be all the dark side we see in
Batman V Superman in this you know this
nightmarish sequence or do you think we
will actually see a version of Darkseid
do you think that they'll play that card
somehow I don't feel like they would
push it that hard I think that they
would just tease it with something like
this like hey everybody you see this you
see this you can just feel sacs Nider
and Geoff Johns winking at you from
behind the camera and if you haven't
been reading Darkseid war Justice League
dark side war in the comics be sure to
check it out it is full of new gods and
I want to give too much away but Geoff
Johns without completely retconning the
anti-monitor character really changes
his character in an interesting way it's
really more than anything it's an
anti-monitor story that I feel like is
something that they won't get to for a
long long time in the DC movie universe
the idea of the anti-life equation and
the idea of the antimatter universe and
the anti-monitor but what I'm gonna do
now is I'm just gonna replay like the
last big trailer see if you can spot all
of the references to the new gods and
Darkseid knowing now that they are
definitely in there so here we go
[Music]
was then you must be new that is first
Wayne
[Music]
this away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the bat vigilante in
Gotham civil liberties are being
trampled on their city
people living in fear thinks he's above
the law the Daily Planet
criticized and notices things are above
the laws Oh hypocritical
what's your self considering every time
your hero saves a cat out of a tree you
ready off piste editorial
about an alien gonna burn the whole
place down
most of the world doesn't share your
opinion mr. Wayne
maybe Gotham City and me
a bad history with freaks dressed like
clowns
boys hmm Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it
I love bringing people together how are
we Lex hi hello Lex it is a pledge ow
wow that is a good grip you should not
pick a fight with this person you know
the oldest lie in America senator but
power can be innocent
some [ __ ] brought the war to us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat of Gotham
you're psychotic it's a three syllable
word for any thought too big for little
minds
tiny bird what it means to be a man
now I wanted it you'll be dead already
man won't kill God
yellow will do it
what have you done
he would you I thought she was you
so it's gonna be a lot of fun and Zack
Snyder was teasing a little bit more
about like the final parts of the film
in that Lex Luthor is really interested
in the idea of metahumans and he
actually used that word metahumans so I
like the way that they share that with
the TV universe where like Fox has its
mutants Marvel has its Inhumans in it's
enhanced in DC across its TV movie
universes has metahumans so don't be
surprised if doomsday is just like the
tip of the metahuman iceberg with Lex's
experiments real quick a mine or two
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway going on now I
wasn't planning on doing a new Batman V
Superman video so I'll announce the
winner whenever I post my flash video
then all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so case you guys haven't seen it I
totally just posted this funny Deadpool
proposal brown eye trailer you'll know
what I'm talking about once you've seen
it you can click here to watch that yeah
you can click here for all my other
Batman V Superman videos thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight